what was your first experience with
Bitcoin and like what drew you into it
I was the attraction - yeah the tape
yeah so I my first interaction with
Bitcoin was actually transacting on the
Silk Road you know free Ross if any if
anybody listening doesn't know the Ross
Ulbricht story that's it's a great story
you know despite the fact that he was
framed so so free Ross but that was my
first exposure to Bitcoin and and first
it just seemed like a sort of gimmick
fad fake Internet token that and I
didn't even think twice about it I
didn't think about scarcity I didn't
think about you know anything else and
then sort of later that year in early in
2013 was when I first started to look
into it and and sort of think through
you know hey well what why are people
interested in this what is the appeal
who works on it right because you know
admittedly and this is kind of
embarrassing the first time I saw a
Bitcoin I actually thought it was a
company I didn't realize it was this you
know sort of globally distributed
network I thought you know I was like
what's this company Bitcoin you know who
runs it well what are they working on I
can't find a website yeah they got some
wild right exactly I was like this is
kind of a crazy idea I was like I love
it and so that was that was my first
exposure wasn't until later that I
actually read the white paper I tried
running a node I bought I bought my
first Bitcoin before that it was via why
I did a Western Union transfer to Japan
actually and to buy money on to buy
Bitcoin on mal Cox still involved in
that in that class action but it seems
like we're getting paid so there's some
good things that happen and the you know
once it all sort of clicked you know
how it was you know sort of resistant to
government shutdown what the the sort of
novelty was around you know having a
digital scarce resource etcetera you
know once that clicked you know
everything kind of made sense from there
and but it took me a long time I
remember I looked at it recently I was
looked I looked back at you know fine
finding it from over five years ago to
figure out what was the first thing I
ever said about Bitcoin on the Internet
and the first thing I ever said about
Bitcoin on the internet it is played
around with Bitcoin a little bit today
looks interesting but not sure the UX is
there for the mainstream and we're here
five years later and the UX is
substantially better companies like
coinbase exist now bit co ledger do you
know there are a number of great wallets
there are a whole host of exchanges
there's a lot of places where you can
spend your Bitcoin a lot of merchants
payment tools but the UX still you know
could use a lot of work and and it's
something that dozens of teams are
working on so it's awesome